Today on the podcast. Robert, we're going to talk, um, constitutional law, uh,
federalism and uh, and the intricacies of international treaty practice.
Oh God. You're ready. No, no. It's going to be good. It's going to be good.
It's gonna be good cause I have. Hello. Hey guys. Hi Kelsey. Hello.
Kelsey Padgett has reported this segment and just listen to how it starts.
So the story starts with a betrayed spouse.
We see in those much better. I'm coming back to my seat. You get some popcorn?
My name is Dunkin Hollis. He's not the betrayed spouse. Nope.
I'm a professor of international law here at Temple University in Philadelphia
and I'm Nick Rosencranz and not him either.
I'm a professor of law at Georgetown.
I'm also a senior fellow in constitutional studies at the Cato Institute.
So Mrs. Bond, that's her. That's our Patreon spouse.
Carolyn Bond 36 lives in a suburb of Philly.
Discovered that her husband was having an affair with her neighbor. Actually,
it was worse than that. This woman is her best friend.
Not only that, uh, she finds out that her friend is pregnant, uh,
via her husband. He got her practice.
Oh my God. Yeah. And this is her best friend and her husband had 14 years,
you know, she was quite upset, distraught, enraged, I would imagine. Yeah.
Carol made threats. There were confrontations.
The other woman is named Melinda Hanes by the way. And eventually
Carolyn Bond, she did what anyone would do.
She got a bunch of toxic chemicals and I do it all the time.
And she tried to poison her best friend repeatedly or the backup for a second.
Where would she have gotten the chemicals from? She worked, I believe at a lab.
She works for a chemical company, I think it's Roman Haas.
So she's a biochemist. She's actually a microbiologist, but she uh,
grabbed some chemicals from her office.
I think she also ordered some off the internet,
amazon.com but they're pretty serious chemicals. Like what? Well,
one was arsenic based and in large enough doses.
And when I say large doses, I'm talking teaspoons, not gallons. It can,
you know, um, cause serious injury and can be fatal. So anyway,
she took these chemicals, she went over to her best friend's or well,
her former best friend's house,
and she spread them on the door knob and on the mailbox,
the door to her car. And they're visible, I guess. I guess you can see them.
So the best friend is unfold. Nope. She calls actually the local police,
local police tell her to take her car to a car wash. They said, Yo, you know,
it could be drugs, would get the car washed off. They kind of just blow her off.
Uh, but it keeps happening over the course of like half a year.
This happens 24 times 24 powder attack according to the court briefs.
You know, the police were just not being very responsive.
She called them over a dozen times and they tested it to see if it was cocaine.
But once they figured out it wasn't, they didn't really do anything.
So finally tells the post office and it was the post office that actually sent
out postal inspectors and they set up a hidden camera and they videotaped
Caroline bond in the act. They get it on tape.
That's how they identify her as the person putting the chemicals, you know,
on the mailbox. I didn't know the post office did stuff like that to be honest.
I didn't either. That's so, I think of them so differently now. Yes.
And I'm, I think if there's a moral to the story, it is,
do not mess with the males. They take that, they take that very seriously.
Actually, there's a whole lot more going on than just messing with the mail
because of what happens next. Um, so according to Nick Rosenkranz,
generally things like assault or tempted murder, those are state crimes.
In most circumstances. The federal government can't charge you with murder.
The post office, that's a federal institution.
So when they caught Caroline bond,
they kicked this up to the federal attorney who then went ahead and brought a
federal keys.
And here's the thing,
they ended up charging Carolyn Bond with [inaudible] violating the international
chemical weapons treaty. What we should be clear,
the victim got a tiny thumb Byrne and ran cold water on it and was fine.
So this is, we're not, this is, um, this is not murdered.
All the more odd, very odd. When I played in someone, I'm,
the last thing I'm thinking about is violating an international treaty.
We should never have you over for lunch. But no, really,
why would they charge you with that? I don't understand. Well,
if you actually read the treaty,
the statutes and police says that it's a crime to use a toxic chemical for other
than a peaceful purpose. That's the exact language. And that guy that,
that's John Bellinger.
I served as the legal advisor for the Department of State Under Secretary
Condoleezza Rice. And John says that even though it sounds a little weird,
this is exactly what this treaty was meant for, for people using chemicals,
highly toxic chemicals or non peaceful purposes. Exactly right.
And that's what happened here.
Imagine if she had killed a bunch of postal workers then I don't think anybody
would complain. But the charger with an international treaty violation,
that just seems, it seems too big for the little lady.
It was really odd to her lawyers too. I bet they're like, look,
in the constitution you have laid out what the federal government could do.
This is not one of those things.
You can't just take a treaty and use it to reach into the very local life of a
normal person. That's a huge overreach. Sneaky frankly.
And now this case is before the Supreme Court and it's become an ideological
battle that goes way beyond Carolyn Bond,
her cheating husband or her adulterous best friend.
And I would argue that this case is weird as it is racist,
some really important, uh,
issues about how the world is changing and about one of the most fundamental
questions that is at the heart of America.
I really believe that. Well, you have to defend that position. What do you,
what do you mean? Let me take you back to the beginning. Okay, sure.
My name is Joseph J. Ellis. I am a historian.
I've written the book called founding brothers.
And my most recent book is called, what's it called?
Revolutionary Summer. You have a modest man.
Joseph Ellis has written a Pulitzer Prize winning author.
He's written a bunch of books about the founding of our country. Um,
the revolutionary war,
and there is a scene in one of his books were called American creation didn't
sell as many as sounding brothers.
It doesn't matter to me because he has this one passage that when I read it,
I was like, wow, I've never thought of this country that way.
But to set the scene, or you want to be real specific, September,
September, 1787 in Philadelphia, you know, it's abominably hot.
Yet all of these great men crammed into a State House.
I mean George Washington Fisk guy is a stud
63 and war hero. This is overwhelming. Alexander Hamilton was there, Hamilton,
he would've got the highest grades on the LSA teas. I'm telling you,
this guy was really smart. Even Ben Franklin who's pushing 81 at this point,
Franklin Stair, oh, they all came together to try and figure out like,
how do we do this? Like if you think about it,
it was a puzzle because you've got these 13 colonies,
which are really like sovereign nations.
They were loosely organized into a federation. That was about to go bankrupt,
so they had to do some things. They're like, okay,
let's bring them together into a union, but how do we do that without a king?
It was a crazy experiment. What do I mean? One thing,
you got to realize that at that time in American history,
the average person was born,
lived out his or her life and died within a 30 mile radius.
They don't have cell phones and they don't think about themselves as Americans.
They thought of themselves as Pennsylvanians, south Carolinians, Bostonians.
There is no real national ethos, so that's one problem. Second problem,
the founding fathers could not agree,
could not agree on the most basic question if there's not a king who's in
charge, right? The so-called sovereignty question,
and on the one hand you had a guy like Alexander Hamilton who got up there and
was like, why do we even need states? What's the state? All right,
what we need is a federal government that is big and strong and powerful.
That's Hamilton. Baby Hamilton wants a president elected for life.
Hamilton wants a senator elected for life. On the other hand,
you had the Thomas Jefferson School of thought, which is like, no, no,
we just got out of a monarchy for Christ sake and the only way we're not going
to get back in one is if we keep the government small restricted and all
domestic policy belongs in the hands of the states. Sound familiar?
Jefferson likes anything in which the government's not going to be doing much.
So you had these two very different philosophies and the way Joe sees it,
you let Jefferson have total power. We're end up at anarchy.
You could let Hamilton have total power.
You're going to end up with the totalitarian state at the convention.
The two sides went back and forth and any time a Hamiltonian type proposal hit
the floor, some of the states would say, oh no,
and they shoot it down because they did not want some big government telling
them what to,
especially when the 800 pound gorilla in the room was slavery.
So they couldn't agree at all. And into this mess walks our hero.
James Mattson. Madison. Yeah. Like Madison is five to one 20.
He's the kind of guy that stands in the corners during the dance.
He's you would call him a nerd or you might call him a pragmatist.
Madison wants a clear decision about sovereignty. Yeah.
Like for example on local matters who gets the final say the states or the
federal government, just give me some clarity and uh, he's not going to get it.
And he comes to that realization at the very end.
Cause at the end of the convention they have this document.
I mean he wrote the original blueprint. Now there's this new document.
So riddled with compromises that according to Joe,
the basic question he wanted answered wasn't the WHO's in charge.
Question was left kind of vague on all sorts of matters.
I mean who regulates money in banks? Who gets to tax? What?
Who decides whether new states will be slave states or free states? Who's vague?
And initially Gordon Joe in a letter that Madison wrote to Thomas Jefferson,
he's like, come on, he's very disappointed.
He thinks the document's going to fail and the country's going to fail.
He doesn't think this is going to last. But then Joe says in his writings,
you start to see a shift. He starts to think differently.
He starts to say, Oh yeah, wait a second. This,
this could work precisely because it's unclear.
And we found what he calls a middle station where everyone can see what they
want to see. I mean, people come out of the convention, go back to their states,
and the guy in South Carolina says, don't worry about slavery.
Lieutenant Amendment's going to tell us that they can't do that.
The guy in Pennsylvania and says,
it's just a matter of time before we have slavery.
The constitution becomes successful because the people don't agree on what it
means.
That according to Joe was Madison's epiphany with the constitution isn't a set
of answers. It's a framework for argument.
This is a document which allows us to continue to discuss and debate the core
issues that we faced, the powers of the presidency, the sovereignty question,
the real resolution of the sovereignty question is never is never achieved.
And um, and it eventually leads to the civil war.
I find kind of neat about this is that like that argument that happens in modern
politics all the time about states' rights or the size of the government,
which can feel like a random argument for me at times suddenly to know this.
I mean if you by what Joe's saying, it's not random at all.
This is an argument that was actually literally written into our founding
document. In some sense. We as a country are the product of that argument.
Of course, not everybody agrees with Joseph Ellis.
There are people who who think that the fathers had a very specific thing in
mind and if you just go back to their debates and to what they said to each
other, that you can find the real only deep logic for the constitution.
So the fact that they disagree with Joe in some sense,
doesn't that kind of make Joe's point? Okay,
I can do this document in 10 different ways. Yes.
Everyone always argues always just to pick up the thread.
I mean after the civil war, the argument changes, it gets centered,
but the union is still an experiment. Yeah.
Massachusetts can still do their business differently than Colorado,
differently than Vermont,
and the jostling between the federal government and the state government doesn't
end. It just gets a little quieter. Thank heavens, because you don't want,
unless you're a duck. And our next stop is,
and this one has everything to do with our poisoner.
So it's spring of 1919 rural Missouri.
You've got frank mcallister, the attorney general of Missouri.
He's out there with a bunch of friends and they're pointing their guns at the
sky and shooting them one after another after another,
and they ended up shooting all in all 76 he knows he can do this because you
know he's the attorney general of the state.
He knows all the laws of the state and he knows it's his right to shoot whatever
duck is flying in the sky of Missouri is to state law. That's the state law.
You can shoot the ducks. So they're out there have,
they're having this great time, they're having this great hall.
They'd gotten all these ducks. And then out of nowhere, Ray Holland,
the federal game warden shows up and he says, no, you, you can't do this.
You can't shoot these birds. They're not your property. MCALLISTER says you,
you're wrong. This is a matter for the state. You know, it's our sovereignty.
We never gave this over to the federal government. So you must have been like,
I don't think the federal government anything to say to be able to duck that it
was born here. I leave the, I looked, I found it in the sky here.
I shot it here, it died here and I'm going to eat it here.
So this is my duck that the game warden says, no, it's not your duck.
And he rest them all setting up a landmark confrontation.
Because here's what had happened two years earlier.
The administration of Woodrow Wilson was sitting there wringing their hands
thinking all these people are killing birds at like a nonstop pace.
And if this didn't stop, no.
There was some concern at this period that we were going to, you know,
we were going to hunt these things for extinction. You know,
we might not have any migratory birds at all.
Problem is the courts had already told the federal government,
this is surely a local matter, you can't make federal hunting laws.
But then somebody in the administration has this really great idea or really
evil idea depending on how you look at it.
Maybe if we can get Canada to cooperate with us,
we can do this by a treaty because there's this clause in the constitution that
says treaties are the supreme law of the land.
So maybe if we make it international treaty,
then the states will to go along. Frank mcellister,
he sues and this goes all the way up to the supreme court.
It lands before Oliver Wendell Holmes, one of the more famous, uh,
justices of the supreme court. And he basically says,
the treaty power is something that was given to the federal government.
Don't limit this. This treaty is good. And, uh,
the treaty and the legislation are upheld and score one for the federal
government score, one for the federal government. And in there, um,
you actually have homes talking about what the constitution is. He, you know,
he was this what,
thrice wounded civil war veteran and he actually invokes the language of,
of the civil war saying we, you know, we spent all this, um,
sweat and blood to figure out what kind of nation we were going to become for
birds.
He invokes this language and basically says whatever we had debated in the past,
you know, could the states regulate slavery without federal interference?
And home says, no. You know that the side who fought that argument, they lost
[inaudible]
all this talking about birds and you know,
state versus federal has everything to do with our poisoner and bond.
This case is the precedent upon which the federal government says that they can
prosecute Caroline lawn because Oliver Wendell Holmes said that treaties are the
supreme law of the land. I don't know. I, I'm still,
I'm still of the mind that this is a sneaky bit of business by the,
by the federal government. I mean, it's not sneaky. If you're a duck,
I feel, I must speak on behalf of the dogs here, but no, forget your ducks.
This is a Pennsylvania lady doing a Pennsylvania adultery in a Pennsylvania
mailbox with a Pennsylvania mood. I mean, there's nothing,
there's no birds flying overhead. This is an all Pennsylvania crime.
But you know, who wasn't doing it? God Damn thing about that. Pennsylvania eggs.
Oh, oh. But just to take your side for a second, Robert, um,
if you really think about it and you know,
and the way that Nick Rosenkranz thinks about it, this is really troubling.
This decision seems to say that theoretically the federal government's power is
potentially infinite.
No, no, no.
Cause like, say John Kerry, who's our secretary of state right now,
he goes and makes treaties,
say he's talking to Zimbabwe and we agree that we want to have a treaty about
educational standards for children.
So we come home and we write a law that says all children must go to public
schools, but then that would outlaw homeschooling for children,
which is a clear local state matter.
But now suddenly the federal government has a power to do that just seems odd.
The idea that, uh, the president,
the Senate in Zimbabwe can increase Congress's legislative powers.
Here's how John Bellinger response.
Is it a theoretical possibility that the federal government might try to go and
do that? I suppose it's theoretically possible,
but there's no evidence that that happened here.
There's no evidence that that has happened in the a hundred years since Missouri
versus Holland. He would say, look,
consider the practical impact that it decision might have that would cut back on
the president's treaty power.
Other countries are already highly suspicious of the United States ability to
deliver on it's a tweedy commitments anyway. John would say,
why would any other country want to make it treaty with us if Kansas could back
out at any time and like how do you do deal with a question like global warming
if everybody is allowed to be left to their own devices? Well now that's a,
that's a tough one. I mean the reality is that stuck in Hollis, again,
we live in a globalized world. Whether it's, you know,
dealing with things like climate change, terrorism, shipwreck, cyber crime.
Increasingly these are things we can no longer regulate just within a particular
local community or a local society. And like on some level,
if we now find ourselves in this world where like I can get on the Internet and
spend hours and hours playing world of Warcraft with people in Yugoslavia and
yet, and I've never really talked to my neighbor that's just down the street,
like why wouldn't we all have the same laws? But you know,
I think the flip side of your question is find the world is very interconnected,
but are there still some things that are local?
Are there some things left where we could say the federal government doesn't
need to be able to reach this? And more than that,
nick says that having a bunch of different communities that are governed by
different rules all under the same nation, actually
it has a bunch of benefits. Um, competition. This,
the idea of laboratories of democracy that the 50 states will all try different
things as to regulating guns near schools, as to regulating whatever it is.
And maybe some state we'll hit on something brilliant. And if they do,
then it will spread and be replicated and you know that theory has been born out
in a lot of different areas.
When the feds decided that they're going to come up with a one size fits all
national solution, that's the end of the experiment.
Oh,
so by the way, wait, what happened to Carolyn [inaudible]? She went to,
she's in jail. She's still in jail? No, she's out now. So she's,
she could go to court and find out whether this thing was high school.
She can show up. What about the, the, the poison. He what? What happened to her?
She changed her name. She moved away. She's uncertainty now.
I hope she moved to Zimbabwe. Is She's still living with the guy that gave,
gave her the baby or no, no, no, no. You see,
you see Carol even though she went to jail for six years,
she stayed with her husband. Oh, no way. Really? Yeah.
She stayed with the man who had a baby with the other lady that she tried to
poison that lady about. She stayed with that guy. See, that's the thing.
Law is interesting, but love. That's complicated. Love is greed within treaties.
Thank you, Kelsey. Thank you Kelsey pageant, carver crawler, boom. Rod. Yeah,
that's all of us. I think you've mentioned all of us. Yeah, let's go.
So we'll use to say goodbye to all of you. Bye. Happy Christmas.